No drugs, no drugs, no alcohol. No.
He drank a little wine though, right?
No Fat Pussy. I'm telling you
that shit will kill Ya. No fat.
No a little allergic.
I'm a big fan for those who want, but
no, I have to drink a little wine though.
I do drink a little wine, but I don't
think that qualifies as a drink.
A glass of wine with the meal. My sons
and my daughters, my brothers, sisters,
they Thanksgiving dinner, beer beers,
better than coke. Right? Vastly.
It's when you start to enter the drools
zone and I have a big problem of course.
And all of a sudden if there's a problem,
I can't rely on you anymore.
I want to be reliable and that's why I
have a problem with comfortably numb.
I think in my experience,
you can't wake up the bass player
cause he's comfortably numb.
The guys don't show up.
He can't tune his guitar.
He forgot the lyrics were not as
tight as we could be. You're fired.
I know what you're saying, but this
is what I'm saying to you, is it?
This is just a discipline issue and it's
not the marijuana or anything that gets
people like that.
It's a lack of discipline.
I you in the digital world and the
Jujitsu world is filled with people that
smoked pot and these mother
fuckers work hard, but they want,
what's the number one karate
guy who was the guy that died?
Bruce Lee. Bruce Lee
did. He spoke dope. Aww.
He ain't hash eight hash. Yeah. You know,
he's into eating hash. Here's my question,
but that's not what killed him.
Here's, here's my question to you.
As I offered to my son Rocco [inaudible]
because he's an advocate of marijuana.
Yes. Okay. And I sat Rocco
and I said, and I said,
so do you really believe that perfectly
clean and sober [inaudible] taking care
of your health with a conscientious diet,
good athletic workout,
discipline,
physical prowess.
Do you really think that an
outside source, payoti mushrooms,
dope,
whatever you want to call it,
do you really think that with that
outside influence you can do something you
can't do unto your God given gift,
individual self.
I'm convinced Joe,
that you will be the
absolute best you can be.
You will accomplish what I think is
a self inflicted curse of modern man.
That 90%,
98% of humanity might be tapping into 5%
of their capabilities because they get
an a treadmill. They
get an uh, a paradigm,
self restricted pier nine ever.
So decreasing a view of the world
and experiences and the overwrote the
destroyed road over traveled versus not
only the road less traveled but the non
road untraveled that's my favorite.
I'm convinced that you Joe Rogan. Hmm.
We'll find your superior definitive
best without any outside influence.
I believe you have the par.
I think I have the power when I get
onstage tonight and you gotta come,
you gotta come witness this but
my bed and I do like it out.
We'll figure out a time. I
can't come tonight. Secondly,
I got an orgy show at
the Improv of human fire.
We put our fists together and Chant
James Brown and Wilson picket and funk
brothers and it's like the last wolves
on an island give gnashing of teeth over
the last bone in Shard
of flesh. It's, it's a,
it's an out of body
soaring above life itself
experience that we have in us.
I don't need anything. I
understand me, I understand that.
But you don't use anything,
so you're,
you're talking from a place of non
experience when it comes to marijuana or
mushrooms or any of these things.
But my 70 years,
I say at least 55 of those years from
the beatniks to the hippies to the,
to the friends and you got to meet this
Wayne Kramer Guide Mc five guitars,
new book, the hard stuff. He and I were
born the same time, same influence,
Detroit, the swamps, the outdoors. But Bo
Diddley, Chuck Berry, Motown, James Brown,
he started smoking dope.
I didn't. And he's, uh,
in any got a heroin and the
credit and any prison. Again,
stealing and then arrested and I'm
having the time of my life and he's like
wallowing and assess pool in dog shit.
And I'm not knocking Wayne. I'm saying
that he was courageous to write this book.
It's a brilliant book. You got to
have them on. You're going to read it.
You're going to,
you're going to be consumed by his
conversational writing of the MC fives,
a ascension to the most authoritative
power house music I've ever witnessed in
my life,
to a bunch of dirt bags on the downward
spiral because of drugs and alcohol.
I know that happens. It definitely
happens. But it happens with everything.
It happens with people when
they eat too much food.
It happens with people with gambling.
It happens as the merchant,
different things.
But I think it's because of discipline.
It's because they don't have a clear path.
I think it's cause they let themselves
become self indulgent and they let
themselves be weak. But I'm saying is
that I know a lot of people who use,
whether it's psychedelics or they use
marijuana and they use it to enhance their
perspective, it doesn't become
the primary focus of their life.
It doesn't consume their life.
They don't allow it to consume their life.
There's a whole other world of disciplined
marijuana enthusiasts and they're
confused the same way people confuse
hunter's same way people think of hunters
as being lazy,
drunk and so cruel to animals.
And you and I know that that's not the
case at all. Some of the most disciplined,
focused and best people know are intense
people because to the be at Cameron
Hanes,
to be a John Dudley,
you have to be a superior type of
human being should breath leach. Yeah.
You have to be able to execute
in that extreme moment,
that moment where that animal walks
out to that shooting window and you're
looking at this three 90
bull elk and help screaming,
screaming,
and overwhelming all over itself,
overwhelming and it's 40 yards
away and your center in that pen,
it takes the magic powerful
human being to execute that shot.
And I don't think most
people are aware of that.
Most people don't know in the same
way that that's misunderstood.
I think marijuana is misunderstood
because there's a lot of dummies in this
world.
If you get a group of 100 people,
what are the odds that one of
them's going to be a dummy?
Fucking 100% right and more
nowadays more than one. Yeah. Well,
if you get a group of a hundred
people that use marijuana,
the one loud fucking stupid one defies
or defines rather what marijuana users
are. You see that fucking
idiot who's pissing all over
himself and fallen down so
high he can't walk.
That's what you think of.
You don't think of the Brazilian Jujitsu
black belt at smokes pot and then goes
out and strangles 50 people in in class.
You don't think of people to take
yoga class. I liked hiring marijuana.
Strangling. There should be
a nice whole, Eh, listen,
I am absorbing, absorbing, in,
respecting and considering your
word. It can get away from you. Yeah,
you can get away from me. All I've ever
said, everything can get away from you.
That's all I've ever seen. But I think
it's because these people that consume it,
they don't have those other qualities.
They don't have discipline and focus.
They don't have respect for their body.
See the thing with that,
especially in the Jiu Jitsu community,
it's super common. Marijuana is really,
really, really, really
common. Yeah. I mean they,
there's a show called high
rollers where these guys,
they put together a Jujitsu tournament
and everybody had to get high before they
rolled.
And you're talking like elite world
class Brazilian Jiu black belt competing
high on marijuana and that's gotta be
one of the highest forms of disciplines
very available to us. It's a very,
very right there with the camera names.
Mountain climbing bowl, calling an oak
in your lap. Yes. Well you're, you're,
you're doing an art that's designed to
break bodies and the two of you are going
to do it together.
And the whole idea is that you're going
to get someone into a position where
they have to tap or they're going to get
their arm snapped or they're going to
get choked unconscious. It's
intense, extremely difficult pursuit.
And a lot of people do it under
the influence of marijuana.
Do you know any of these? Master
Jujitsu Martial Artis? Oh yeah.
That that don't do any, oh yeah.
Oh yeah, and how do they perform?
They perform well. Do very
well. There's, let's look.
There's the elite world class athletes
in Jujitsu that don't generally I won the
world champion got high or not well.
I know a lot of them I do,
but I know a lot of them do.
A lot of world champions do.
I know a lot of like real
multiple time world champ didn't.
They're marijuana users. Yeah. How about
world champions that don't get high?
There's a lot of those to see.
What happens with marijuana is,
is increased sensitivity that a lot
of people talk about and they talk,
they call it paranoia because there's a
lot of things that people put blinders
on their life. A lot of
people aren't aware and I'm
sure because of your hunting,
you're spending time in the woods, you're
soaking in all the variables, the sound.
When I'm a radar, you're
there, right? You're aware.
There's a lot of people that
go through life like this,
no pick go through life like
they're looking through a
toilet paper roll over in
the left lane right now they're not.
They're not using their blinkers.
And those people, those people, when
they smoke marijuana, they freak out.
They get paranoid because what's
happening is the marijuana increases your
sensitivity.
He makes you aware of all these variables
and a lot of people consider that
paranoia. You start freaking
out about all these variables.
He started thinking about your mortality
and instead of embracing this time as a
magical moments that of
being in this moment,
you just start getting overwhelmed and
you feel your own heartbeat and you start
freaking out of this all the
time. Yeah. It's without anything.
It's an entheogenic.
It brings you closer to whatever
you are not encumbered by your ego.
I will
admit in escapable that everything
affects everyone differently.
Yes.
But once you make it widespread,
I mean I've studied the
results of legalization for
recreational use in Colorado
and how the highway fatalities
and accidents have increased,
but you know what else is increased
the population in proportion.
So it causes breeding. Taz is more
people there, more people are there,
so you having more accidents there.
The problem is,
is a boom of population
also boom in the economy,
a boom in the real estate,
real estate's taken off. Yeah.
There's a lot of losers there too. There's
a lot of hacky sack playing, dirty,
stinky hippies that are wandering
around with no shoes on.
You're going to get those. You're
going to get those. You know,
if you have an opening welcome society
that's, that doesn't lock those people up,
you're going to have those. It's a
part of freedom. Yeah, it sucks. Look,
losers are a part of this safe world that
our kids are allowed to wander through.
We want the world to be safe,
so sometimes things are too safe.
You nerf the edges and you get a bunch
of people that are used to hitting their
heads on things and they're
not worried about it.
You're going to have these losers, but
it doesn't mean that everybody who does,
it's a loser. I know a lot of CEO's of
big corporations that have extreme rights
responsibilities and they like
to smoke a little pot. I get,
I get punched back off and on Facebook,
I'm a successful guy,
run my family, I'm a good dad,
I'm a good hunter and I'm a,
I'm a Trump supporter and I get high
like, Oh God bless you. It just,
I don't want you, you know, babysitting
my kids while you're high. Yeah.
But it's discipline.
Discipline is the thing that fucks people
up and the lack of this lack of the
lack of discipline. And I think that's
what everything, it could be with sex,
it could be with gambling,
it could be with extreme risky behaviors.
People could just get, get real nutty
and get carried away with things.
And sometimes those things are just a big
distraction for the lack of discipline
they have in pursuing
their own goals in life.
I think that that is
the real high in life.
The real high in life is pursuing
difficult things. Ratification. Yes.
Getting good at them and then
accomplishing your goals. There's a,
there's a high to that that's,
you can't find that in pills.
It doesn't exist in a needle.
That high is a high of discipline and
determination and focus and learning,
but there's so much weakness out there,
especially in a society has been spoiled
for so long and you get a trophy if you
don't even show up and you can't
hurt people's feelings and bullied,
get bullied and you're crying,
stood up, fight and back. I mean,
there's so many manifestation
of a cultural deprivation
that runs a muck in our
society that my fear is,
and I've studied all these mass shootings.
Joe, the Virginia Tech shooter.
Hi, well, they're all buying.
Hi. Yeah, but they're all on SSR. I's,
they're all on pills and pharmaceuticals.
Almost all of them are a presence
on the PROZAC and their parents.
All of them are chemical covering
up a kid that shows enthusiasm.
It's called attention disorder now.
I mean,
if they had that back when I was
growing up, I had end up playing,
I don't know it. I ended up being Ozzie,
and the problem is the word drugs,
like you and I are drinking coffee. We're
on drugs right now. We're on caffeine.
This is a drug. There's some drugs
that if used responsibly or, okay.
A glass of wine with dinner is a
drug. Understood. It's a mild drug.
A little tiny toke. Yeah.
For sex with the misses.
That's a little drug.
It makes you most see.
I've never smoked because I can't smoke.
I get in when I shoot my machine guns,
all I do is chew on a Cuban.
I don't really smoke it.